Hi, welcome back. Welcome to video number
two. You managed to survive video number
one. Well done. If you remember in video
number one, we essentially defined what a
professional trader is. Now we can
actually try and move on towards working
out what a successful professional trader
actually does.
Now, the objective of this video series
throughout is to provide you, the retail
trader, with a framework that enables you
to emulate consistently profitable
professional traders.
Now, to get to that point, what we first
need to do is actually work out why the
majority of retail traders lose money.
Now, you'll probably think to yourself,
well, is that actually true? Do the
majority of retail traders lose money?
Well, yes, they do. And the majority of
retail traders lose money for some quite
specific reasons.
That's the problem in the retail trader
market, and that's the problem we're
trying to solve here.
Now, if you're going to consistently
emulate profitable traders, successful
traders, you're first going to have to
understand all the mistakes that bad
amateur retail traders make.
This will then provide you with a
foundation that enables you to move
towards consistent profitability and
emulating successful professional traders.
So, that's what you're going to see in
this video. That's what you're going to
see in this video. You're going to see
that foundation. You're going to see the
reasons why retail traders lose money.
Once you've got that, we're going to work
towards getting an approach which emulates
successful professional traders.
So, let's go over to the stage. Let's look
at those reasons. I want you to always
think about your objectives here, which is
to use your own money to enable you to
make money in the financial markets.
And when we go through these reasons,
you're going to see some home truths that
really will lay the foundation which will
enable you to move towards consistent
profitability.
Let's go over to the stage, and I'll see
you at the end of video two with a summary
of everything that you see on stage.
Has anybody ever seen this before?
It's an industry statistic that's talked
about all the time in the retail trader
market.
The 1990-90 rule.
Does anybody know what it stands for?
90% of the time, 90% of the time, 90% of
the time, 90% of the time, retail traders
lose 90% of their capital, or something
like that?
Close to it.
It stands for 90% of retail traders lose
90% of their money within 90 days.
And it's a pretty well-known statistic.
And what we're looking at here is margin
accounts, margin trading accounts, where
when you put your money into an account,
the money is there and is collateralized
for you to take higher exposure.
So the broker on the other side will lend
you money to trade based on what you put
up front in your trading account.
So 90% of them lose money, but the
objective here is to make money.
But what causes the differences in the
approach?
Why does it exist?
This is really important for you to know,
because when you understand the home
truths and the parameters of the industry
that you operate in,
once you understand that framework, you
can choose to operate in a different way,
and operate within the framework, because
at the end of the day, you don't have a
choice.
You still need to access the market.
That's the infrastructure of the industry
that's required for you to actually be a
retail trader.
But how do you operate within those
parameters and be successful?
Well, the first step is to understand what
the parameters are, have an appreciation
of them.
Once you understand that, you can work out
how to operate within, in a profitable
way.
So why does it exist?
Conflict of interest, you've got to be
aware of it, why it exists and how it
works.
Trading for income.
Platform and tools seduction, as in
believing that a piece of software is
going to give you all the answers you need
to make money.
And information overload, or misuse of
information.
Conflict of interest, awareness.
What you're looking at there is a very,
very simple formula that literally
underpins the industry.
Everything comes back to this.
Price times volume times commission.
So prices in bull markets, in bull
markets, when the market goes up 100%,
prices double.
Volume doubles.
And people charge higher commission rates
because they can.
So that gets maxed.
In bear markets, stock markets halve.
So prices halve.
Volumes dry up because of a lack of
confidence in the investment arena.
Or in the world in general.
And everyone fights for the smaller amount
of business that's available globally.
So everyone reduces their commission rates
to stay alive.
That's all it is.
That's the whole industry.
But that creates a big conflict of
interest.
The conflict of interest causes people to
do things that they don't really want to
do.
So typical retail trader strategy on a
day, coming in flat on the day with no
position.
And the market's about to open.
And the example we're going to use here is
the S&P 500.
So you've got $10,000 in your trading
account.
And the broker will enable you to take
exposure of 10 times that in the S&P 500.
So you decide, okay, today I'm feeling
really clever.
I'm going to buy $50,000 of the S&P 500 on
the open.
Because I think today the market's going
to rally 1%.
So what's 1%?
100 basis points.
So you think with your risk management
awareness that you're clever.
So if you have a 1% target and you're
going to trade out when you've made 1%,
if it goes wrong, what are you going to
cut the position for?
Well, because you've been taught some very
clever risk management techniques,
or at least you think you've been taught
some very clever risk management
techniques,
you stick a 1 to 3 ratio on the target,
the stop loss compared to the target.
So what's a stop loss?
You automatically trade out when it goes
wrong for 0.33 of a loss.
So you get stopped at.
But you trade out automatically if you
make 1%.
So you stick a 1 to 3 ratio on it.
And everyone is told this is a great way
to manage risk.
But what does that actually mean?
Well, if you do a million trades in your
life,
you stick a 1 to 3 ratio on it, on every
trade.
For you to break even, you need to get 33%
of your trades right.
So 33% hit your target and you trade out
automatically.
And 66% hit your stop loss.
You break even.
So if you get 40% right, you're obviously
making money.
So what happens if you pay a commission of
10 basis points to buy and 10 basis points
to sell?
So it's called a round trip.
You pay 10 to put the position on and you
pay 10 to take it off.
What happens?
Well, your upside to begin with, in gross
terms, 1%, $500.
As soon as you do a round trip on the
fees,
your net downside becomes $265 and your
upside becomes $400.
And you go from a break-even threshold of
33% immediately to 66%.
They forget to mention that when they're
teaching you how to trade.
Conveniently.
66% break-even threshold.
Is that possible?
What do you think?
I can tell you now,
the best traders in the world get half
their trades right.
For an amateur retail trader to get 66% of
their trades right is almost impossible.
So we've got 84 traders at the Institute
now.
Only one guy this year has above a 66% hit
rate, win rate.
And why has he got that?
Because he just came in and got really
long at everything at the beginning of the
year.
So all along the way, he's aware of his
risk because I've had to make sure that he
actually understands what he's doing.
But on a long, short portfolio,
professional traders, they'll get about
half their trades right.
Maybe 55%.
But for a retail trader amateur to get 66%
of their trades correct is insane.
So you can see how very, very quickly your
odds can change, your odds of making
money.
But what we haven't looked at here, and
who can connect the dots here?
Look at the target of 1%.
What we haven't done at all here is an
analysis of how likely it is of making 1%
in a day by buying the S&P 500.
So how likely is it?
Someone take a guess.
Huh?
It's what, sorry?
Almost zero.
Okay.
Who agrees?
Who disagrees?
Okay, let's put a percentage on it.
What do we think the probability of making
1% in one day in the S&P 500 is?
Who said 10?
Pretty much spot on.
11%.
So what do we have to do?
You have to probability adjust that 1%.
And what happens when you probability
adjust it?
Your downside exceeds your upside by about
four times.
So what's going to happen?
You're actually just going to get stopped
at.
That's the most stupid thing you'll ever
do in the world as a trader.
But everybody does it.
So let's have a look at the numbers.
And we'll be looking at these numbers more
in depth.
Where this number actually comes from.
In a minute.
Just trying to stop the question, where do
you get the number from?
So gross, well, the net number.
So gross, it was 33% breakeven threshold.
Net, it was 66%.
Probability adjusted.
Well, we get the 11% number from looking
back at 50 years of S&P 500 data.
And we're going to look at that.
And we're going to look at that in a
second.
But essentially, an 11% chance is a 9 to 1
odds against you making that money.
9 to 1 against.
So you have to multiply your upside by
0.11 to probability adjust it to get an
expected return.
So you end up with about around 40, 45
pounds upside.
And 265 pounds downside.
So where do we get this number from?
50 years of data.
We're going to go through it a bit later.
You'll have to have your math heads on.
We'll go through trading for income first.
So we've been through this example of
making $10,000 a month trading the
international forex markets.
But what actually happens?
What are we trading when we're looking at
major currency pairs?
So sterling US dollar, euro US dollar.
Well, it's pretty obvious that if you're
dictating to the market how much you think
you can make per month,
and the market decides, actually, I'm just
not going to move.
So for 20 days in a row, what you're
trying to trade to make $10,000 a month
doesn't actually move.
It stays the same price.
And you buy and sell it at the same price
100 times.
Unpaid commission.
Can you make $10,000?
Of course not.
You don't dictate to the market how much
money you can make over a given time
horizon.
The market dictates to you how much money
you can make.
So it's blatantly obvious that it depends
on the volatility of the asset that you're
trading.
But no one's ever told what the real
volatility numbers are.
Because if you were told, then no one
would really trade.
Which means I can't be on the other side
of that situation.
Because there's no one doing it.
We'll look at this data as well soon.
But when you look at 10, 20 years of
historical data of the major currency
pairs, sterling US dollar, euro US dollar,
on a normal day, which we'll go through a
bit later as well, what we consider a
normal day,
the volatility is up or down 0.25%.
25 basis points.
Like I said, we'll be looking at where we
get these numbers from.
And how we get around them.
And how we operate within the parameters
to actually make money.
What about trading platforms?
I'll give you a free piece of software
that you can download on your computer.
And you can trade from your bedroom.
You can trade from your iPad.
I'm pretty sure soon Apple will give you
the ability to trade on a watch.
But if I give you a free piece of
software, why would I do that?
To encourage you to do this.
Right?
The more free stuff and tools I give you
that have flashing lights and make sexy
noises,
the more you're going to be seduced to
push the button.
Clearly.
So if I put an arcade machine in your
house and it's just got flashing lights,
makes lots of noises,
and you go home from Cass Business School
every evening back to your house,
and while you're having your dinner and
watching your soaps,
it just keeps making noises every five
minutes.
But it costs you 10 pence to play the
game.
What's going to happen?
At some point you're just going to get
bored with what's on TV,
and you're going to put 10p in to see what
happens.
And then you're going to get hooked.
And then I'll come round every month and
just empty the machine,
and then we start again.
It's exactly the same principle.
And this is why guys like Steve Jobs, to
me, were geniuses in a different way,
because they knew through design and
functionality,
if they put something sexy in your hand
and made you pay for it,
which is even more ridiculous,
that you're going to actually at some
point press the button
and download every app that you don't need
in your life.
Because none of it's going to make you
money.
It just makes the vendor, the provider,
That, to me, is why Steve Jobs was a
genius, and he knew that.
That's why he designed it so beautifully,
so you'd go and buy it.
But you'll get lots of seduction
techniques.
And there's nothing more seductive than
receiving something for free.
What you'll see is lots of seduction
techniques
and marketing, like trade like a
professional
with ultimate precision and capability.
That's an advert that's on Bloomberg TV at
the moment.
Let's just go through some home truths.
Does the amount of screens you have make
you a better trader?
First example.
Are they linear?
Is the relationship linear?
The more screens I have, the more money
I'm going to make
in a linear fashion.
Clearly not.
Is it exponential?
At some point, I'm going to have so many
screens
that I can't even fit them in my room.
All you need, really, is two screens.
You just need one for your trading
application.
And by the way, that's if you've got a big
trading account.
And you need one screen for your
applications
that you use to manage your own risk.
Because no trading platform can manage
your risk for you.
Going right back to basics.
Trade like a professional with ultimate
precision and capability.
Download my platform.
But who's the platform for?
It's not for professional traders.
It's for retail traders.
No professional trader anywhere in the
world uses these platforms.
It's a gimmick.
We know what a professional trader is.
It's a guy in an investment bank or a
hedge fund manager.
If you put one of these trading platforms
in front of a hedge fund manager,
he'd just laugh.
Because they have direct market access.
And they just, to get liquidity, they call
the banks.
They don't really care what platform they
use.
As long as it executes well.
And does what it says on the tin.
And they get charged the rate that they
want to pay.
Pretty basic.
It's an execution tool.
Doesn't do anything else for you.
But the perception is that the more
equipment you have,
the better you're going to do.
And this gets rammed down people's throats
because it's free.
This is the making you click situation.
And the people on the other side know that
if they give you something sexy for free,
you're going to click.
It's misinformation.
No professional traders use them.
But also, all of the features of the
platform will be sold to you
as things that you need to trade.
You don't.
There shouldn't be anything on a platform
that you need.
Except buy and sell.
Because outside of that, you're doing all
of your own work.
You shouldn't have to rely on anything on
the platform except buy and sell.
So get it into your heads.
You're going to end up trading like George
Bush.
Upside down.
Buying when you should be selling.
Selling when you should be buying.
So what do you see when you look at that?
Most people see a phone.
I see a trap.
What do you see when you look at that?
That's what you'll see on a trading
screen.
So you'll see the price to buy at.
And the price to sell at.
But you'll see it the other way around.
That's what a professional trader sees.
Professional trader sees the price that
they are selling at to you.
And the price that they are buying at from
you.
So they see the opposite of what you're
seeing.
I really like this statement.
Humans can't trade.
They can only be human.
You need to really understand that.
And over the next two days.
We're going to be using loads of
techniques.
It'll be probably around tomorrow
lunchtime afternoon.
But you've got to desensitize yourself.
To being human.
Because humans make awful traders.
Humans can't trade.
So you've got to desensitize yourself from
that immediately.
Most importantly.
These guys.
The hedge fund managers.
They have access to the casino.
You guys don't.
You're still trading through a broker.
That then goes to the exchange.
So you've got to understand those
parameters.
So does it mean professional traders have
an edge.
Over retail traders.
Does it mean they have an edge.
Of course not.
It's not the execution that makes you a
good trader.
Trading with precision and total control.
It's not.
That's not what makes you a good trader.
You might save a bit of money.
On your execution.
But ultimately over the long term.
That's not what's going to make you money.
How you execute.
And how much you pay.
Is a very small part of trading.
It's less than 1%.
99% of trading is.
Knowing what to buy.
And what to sell.
When to do it.
And how to do it properly.
1% is actually pressing the button.
We'll use a quick analogy.
The Japanese corporate golfer.
Who plays golf here?
Have you ever walked onto the first tee?
At the golf course.
And you see a group of guys.
And they've got all of the gear.
And no idea.
So each of these guys.
The bags.
The clubs.
We've got gold clubs here.
Gold shoes.
5 pounds a ball.
Top of the range balls.
Everything.
Totalling 14,800 dollars per person.
And then the guy on the left walks up.
With his 1,000 pound club.
Swings and misses the ball.
And everyone giggles and says.
Try again Yoshi.
Honestly.
Japanese corporate golfers.
On a Saturday, Sunday morning.
You see them all over the place.
It's hilarious.
But they've got all the gear.
But they just can't play.
What you're better off doing.
Is actually just having a seven iron.
One club.
And going to the driving range.
And learning how to hit the ball first.
Once you can hit the ball.
You then go to the golf course.
And you buy a second hand set.
Of cheap clubs.
And you scramble around the golf course.
For a couple of years.
And get your handicap down.
To a respectable level.
And then.
Once you've done that.
You go and invest in yourself.
And buy a proper set of golf clubs.
Buy some proper clothes.
Shoes.
And then play quite regularly.
But you've got to enjoy it as well.
So why start with everything.
When you don't know anything.
And you don't even know if you like it or
not.
Because the Japanese corporate golfer.
Is not there to play golf.
He's there to do business.
You're going to get offered a variety of
stuff.
With features.
Free stuff.
That can only make your life worse.
As a trader.
You'll be told that it gives you an edge.
But it just doesn't give you an edge.
What gives you an edge.
Is doing everything yourself.
And seeking out.
The information in the market.
That 3% of information.
That's actually relevant.
And taking that information.
Making sense of it.
And turning that into real hard money.
No trading platform.
No trading platform can do that for you.
The trading platform.
Is for execution.
And execution only.
And it's less than 1% of what you'll do as
a trader.
As long as you understand human behavior.
You'll understand that the platform is for
doing a specific thing.
Just buying and selling.
It's for nothing else.
You don't have to rely on anything.
Except your own work.
You want to be the guy with the 7-iron.
Not the Japanese golfer.
So we're going to start with Excel.
PDFs.
Going to get publicly available data.
Working out the odds of making money.
Losing money.
Proper risk management.
Proper ideas.
If you can do that with a 7-iron.
Then you can get all the Japanese
corporate golfer kit.
Five years down the road.
But essentially to begin with.
It's vanity over sanity.
What's sane.
Is going out.
And getting the 3% of information that's
relevant.
And turning it into real money.
And you don't need.
All the equipment to do that.
It's all publicly available.
It's just finding it.
Using that information correctly.
And turning it into real money.
Everything else is just noise.
What about information overload.
Or misuse of information.
What are we looking at there.
We're looking at a newspaper.
On the left hand side.
Reporting a headline.
Dollar falls to record low.
Let's short the US dollar.
Everyone's going to sell it.
Is that a good trade.
Everyone wants to sell it.
Exactly.
By the time it's in the newspaper.
It's happened.
They're reporting yesterday's news.
Every professional trader knows that.
I've not read a financial times for over a
decade.
There's absolutely no point.
It's the manuscript for failure.
It genuinely is.
You do not get your trading ideas from
mainstream media.
Newspapers, TV, online.
Because their objectives are totally the
opposite of yours.
The objective of a newspaper is to sell
newspapers.
The objective of a TV station is to get
ratings.
The objective of a website is to generate
hits on that website.
So what are they going to do?
They're going to report sensationalist
headlines to make stupid people do stupid
things.
And one of the most stupid things you'll
do is buy the newspaper.
The job of a professional trader is six
months before that headline is to predict
that it's going to happen.
And put the position on then.
And then it starts to build momentum.
And the move starts occurring.
Because the information starts seeping out
through the professional trading
community.
And slowly but surely, over a three to six
month period, the news filters out to the
mainstream.
By the time this is in the paper, six
months later, what do professional traders
do on the day that it's in the paper?
They use the liquidity of the morons to
get out.
Because it might have already moved 30,
40%.
By the time it moves, what do you need on
the other side?
You need liquidity to get out of the
position.
And that's when the public come in.
Because now it's been filtered all the way
to the public.
If you don't consume that, and you do what
professional traders do, as in accessing
the right information,
this will enable you to predict the
future.
To take the position six months before.
And then trade out to the morons six
months later.
So your job is really to predict now
what's going to happen in six or 12
months' time.
And take the position now.
It's a very important mindset to get in.
So how do we predict the future?
Well, we're going to start predicting the
future this afternoon.
Well, let's conclude the first session.
Professional trader is a trader full-time
that works at an investment bank, prop,
function, or hedge fund.
The objective of the retail trader is to
utilize their own money and make money
from it.
So you're more closely aligned to a hedge
fund manager.
The function and the perception of what a
trader does is really widely
misunderstood.
A trader in an investment bank has got the
least, one of the least sexiest jobs in
the world, in the modern times.
Because you're up at five, in the opposite
six, and you're overseeing algorithms for
80% of the day.
Why does it occur?
It occurs because of misinformation.
The misinformation stems really from the
conflict of interest that occurs in the
industry.
Professional traders need liquidity on the
other side.
So what happens, well, you need 99% of the
population to be sheep for that to happen.
So professional traders predict the
future.
The sheep tell you what's happening at the
present.
And that's on a rolling basis.
So every single day it's the same
situation.
Every minute of every day.
You need to be aware of the conflict of
interest.
Because once you're aware of that and
you're aware of the parameters, you can
decide, one, whether you want to do it.
Even try.
But secondly, if you do, if you understand
the parameters, you can learn how to
operate within them.
And when you learn how to operate within
them, you stand a much better chance of
making money over time.
Okay, welcome back.
Now, what you just saw on stage is really
important.
It's really important because once you've
identified the reasons why retail traders
lose money,
and why the vast majority of retail
traders lose money, you can take the next
step.
The next step will be, and we'll do this
in later videos, is actually taking the
opposite approach.
And the opposite approach is what all
successful professional traders do.
Now, let's go through the four reasons
again, so we can just summarise and get a
good, clear idea of the main reasons why
retail traders,
and the vast majority of retail traders
actually lose money.
Let's start with the conflict of interest.
It's very important to realise that the
conflict of interest exists.
Because the conflict of interest leads to,
most of the time, having a situation
where, as a retail trader,
if you trade the instruments that you're
told to trade in the way that most people
teach you how to trade them,
all that's going to happen is you're going
to end up in a situation in the numbers
that we saw in the presentation.
And those numbers clearly show that, in
the majority of cases, the odds are
actually against you.
Now, what professional traders do,
successful professional traders, literally
do the opposite.
They realise what the numbers are, and
they take steps to actually make sure that
the odds are in their favour.
We're going to look at that in video
three, where we move on to looking at the
most popular instruments that retail
traders trade,
how they trade them, and what the numbers
actually are.
So we can actually then take that
information, and use the same processes,
but turn the odds in our favour.
We'll show you that in video number three.
That's a very, very important principle to
make sure you're on top of.
Always making sure that the odds are in
your favour.
That's the first principle.
Principle number two leads from this idea
of trading for income.
Now, we've already seen in previous videos
that all successful professional traders,
in fact, all professional traders, have
basic salaries already.
No one trades for income, and no one takes
income from their trading account.
So why do retail traders think they can
trade for income?
Well, it's because of marketing and
misinformation.
Everybody likes to tell you what you want
to hear.
And what you want to hear is that trading
is easy, and you can make money every
month, and you can supplement your income,
or do it full-time, and earn a good income
from it.
Unfortunately, every professional trader
knows this isn't true, and that's why they
have basic salaries.
So trading for income doesn't exist in the
professional world, so why should it exist
in the retail trader world?
This is a very, very important principle
that you need to take on board.
Because this becomes a situation where
professional traders, because they know
this, they look at the market in a very
different way.
And this is the way you should be looking
at the market, because the way a
professional trader looks at the market is
that the market dictates the opportunities
that you have as a trader over any given
time horizon.
Whether it's one day, one week, one month,
a year, it doesn't matter.
The market tells you what your
opportunities are, not the other way
around.
You don't tell the market how much money
you can make in a day, week, month, year.
The market tells you.
So let's go back to this example of the
EURUSD, where, for example, you're about
to trade this market, but you realise that
the EURUSD hasn't moved at all.
So it's a theoretical example.
The EURUSD hasn't moved at all for the
last year.
So it's been the same price every day for
the last year.
Well, all that's going to happen is you're
going to buy and sell the EURUSD at the
same price.
You're never going to make money, and
therefore you can't make an income.
You can't make a profit.
You can't make a loss.
You can't make anything.
You can't do anything.
This is what all professional traders
know, and it's basic, but everybody misses
this situation.
Everybody thinks trading is for income,
when professional traders know, and this
is the important principle, that the
market dictates your opportunities, and
the volatility of that market specifically
dictates those opportunities.
So essentially, your job as a trader, and
you'll hear this saying many, many times,
you're a slave to volatility.
A trader's job is being a slave to
volatility over any given time horizon.
So that's principle number two.
No incoming trading, and the market
dictates your opportunities, not the other
way around.
You are a slave to volatility.
Now, let's have a look at problem number
three with trading platforms and tools.
So we looked at the Japanese corporate
golfer.
People view their trading platform as some
sort of resource that is going to make
them money.
It's not going to make you a better
trader, and that's the truth of it.
What makes you a better trader is actually
being able to use no resources and no
tools whatsoever.
So not paying thousands of dollars for
software, having an all-singing,
all-dancing trading platform.
What's actually going to make you money is
being able to make money with no resources
at all.
Because once you can make money with no
resources at all, you can then make money
with any resource.
And this leads on to principle number
four.
And principle number four is the overload
and misuse of information.
Pretty much every day, you'll hear lots of
information in the world.
That this is important for this situation,
this is important for this situation.
The fact of the matter is, is that
actually the vast, vast majority of
information that you'll hear in the
financial markets every day
isn't going to make you money, and it
isn't going to make you a better trader.
It's not going to make you consistently
profitable.
Why?
Because everything that you see in the
populist media, so in newspapers, on
television, online, on websites, on social
media sites,
it's usually all, in the vast, vast
majority of cases, old news.
It's talking about the past.
And professional traders know that their
job is to predict the future.
So if you can predict the future and
predict what's going to be in tomorrow's
newspaper, or on the websites, or on
television,
all that's going to happen is, is you're
going to take the position before it's
news.
And when it's news, those people who are
reacting to the news are providing you
with the liquidity to get at.
So pretty much 97% of all information in
the world, every single day, is
irrelevant.
It's not going to make you money.
What trading's all about is, it's really a
three-step process.
It's identifying the relevant information
that's potentially going to make you
money,
that's proven to make money over the past.
Then taking that information,
and interpreting it correctly.
There's many people in the world that know
what that information is,
but they don't interpret it correctly.
Once you've interpreted it, it's about
turning it into real hard dollars.
That's principle number four.
Identifying the information that's
relevant,
interpreting it correctly, and turning it
into real hard dollars.
And cutting out all of the noise that
doesn't actually mean anything.
Now once you've done that,
once you've done that,
and you understand the four areas of why
retail traders always lose money,
you can actually move on to identifying
what makes us a successful trader.
And really, it's about doing the opposite.
And that's what we're going to do in video
number three.
So identify those problems,
understand them,
and really stick to those principles.
Because they're the principles that we're
going to be sticking by
all the way through this video series.
Now we're going to move on to video three.
And video three,
we're going to start looking at the retail
trader instruments
that everybody trades,
and the way that they trade them.
And once you see these numbers,
you're really going to understand
the problems that retail traders face,
and the processes that you can take from
that information
to make sure that the odds are actually
turned in your favor.
So let's move on to video three,
and I'll see you then.
Thank you.